so let's have a quick look at some
worked examples now here's this function
that I'm giving you actually will scroll
just up so you can see that for you
there just in case you're madly writing
it down okay here's an inequality that
I'm asking for you to solve and you can
see that first term there X cubed means
this is gonna be a bit of a Wiggly graph
okay and you've got X cubed minus 3x
squared is less than 4x so I'm gonna
follow my own advice I'm gonna solve
this question by getting everything on
one side and making the right-hand side
zero in this case you can see all I need
to do is subtract 4x from both sides so
that gives me this okay now I've got the
left-hand side as I'm kind of the
business end of things right I need to
graph this guy over here and then search
for the place where look at the
direction in inequality where the graph
is below the x-axis where it's negative
okay so I'm gonna try and graph this
thing I'm gonna try and graph y equals x
cubed minus 3x squared minus 4x so
hopefully I know it's over a while ago
now almost two whole weeks but you're
reflexively looking at this and thinking
I should factorize this right so there's
a common factor of X we'll take that guy
out that leaves me with a quadratic in
the bracket and can you go ahead and
tell me what's the pair of numbers
that's going to help me factorize this
can anyone type it in there in the chat
window for me so I know that you're on
the same page with me what pair of
numbers can we use to factorize it can
see they need to come in so have a think
about it carefully
I want remember it's a pair of numbers
they add to negative 3 they multiply to
negative 4 okay yeah we're getting there
thumbs up well done Jason you fixed
yourself up so I'm getting X take away 4
X plus 1 so it's all factorized now from
this I can read off that there are going
to be three intercepts right I'm going
to get an intercept at x equals 0 I'm
going to get one at x equals 4 and then
I'm also going to get one at x equals
negative 1
okay now this is enough information for
me I can go ahead to my pre-prepared
of axes here I can pop these intercepts
on and then I can work out what the
shape of this is roughly going to be
let's see here if I put on a rough scale
let's make that negative 1 and then 0 1
2 3 4 so I'm getting an intercept here
here and here negative 1 that's 0 and
that's gonna be 4 ok this is a cubic so
I'm expecting this graph is gonna wiggle
up and down between these intercepts and
you can go ahead and test the value
again if you want to think about how we
did this with rational functions you can
test a very large value positively or a
very large value negatively which will
tell you that on the left hand side
you're going to have very negative
values and on the right hand side you're
gonna have very positive values so very
roughly I'm gonna try and thread the
needle through my points and you know
what that's it's not beautiful you can
Slee I slightly missed my intercepts but
the part of the graph that I'm
interested in is where am i above the
axis where am i below can I tell that
from this graph and the answer is
absolutely I cam is enough of the shape
there that I and enough information from
the intercepts that I can tell what's
going on having a look back at this
question I want to know when is this
graph x cubed minus 3 x squared minus 4x
when is it remember below the x-axis
when is it negative ok and what I'll do
is I'll literally highlight this on my
graph and if you haven't been using
colors when you've been graphing I
highly encourage you to do so it just
makes it clearer for you to know what's
going on this part of the graph is below
the x-axis and so is this part of the
graph so all I need now are the X values
that give me those blue sections of the
graph so let's have a look at a let's
have a look at this section over here on
the left
um the boundary there is negative 1
right that's that's the spot over there
where I stopped and I want everything to
the left of that everything to the left
of negative 1 so I'm going to go ahead
and write that as X is less than
negative 1 there's the first part and
then when I have a look at this section
in here it starts at 0 and then it goes
all the way over to 4 so I would say
zero this is the section down here is
less than X is less than four and I'm
done that's it I would say it's X is
less than negative 1 or from 0 is less
than X is less than 4 there are my
boundaries okay now a quick question
that should be pointed out you might
notice my inequalities there they don't
actually include the boundaries negative
1 or 0 or 4 I haven't written down about
this I haven't written X is less than or
equal to negative 1 I haven't written 0
is less than or equal to X which is less
than or equal to 4
how could I tell that that was you know
I should not include the boundary
the answer is have a look back at the
original question you see the original
question doesn't include the boundaries
so my answer will not include the
boundary either but we will be careful
with that as you'll see in a second so
let me get rid of this there is my
answer right there I'll just highlight
it in orange so you can see it really
clearly and I use the word or rather
than the word and because there's no X
value that can be less than negative 1
and also simultaneously between 0 & 4
you're either one or the other so that's
why I use the word or rather than and
and I use the word all rather than a
comma because a comma makes it ambiguous
whether you mean or or hand okay just a
minor point there thanks Zack E you
might remember the very first thing that
I did was um I took the original
equation this guy here right and then I
wanted the right-hand side to be 0
because it's easier to think about you
just above and below the x-axis but I
want to just show you really quickly
that these really are equivalent
questions this guy that we started with
in this guy that we've solved here okay
have a look at what desmos says about
the way that we just solved the graph
okay here is X cubed minus 3x squared
minus 4x it's obviously a better looking
graph than mine but it is essentially
the same thing same intercepts same
overall shape I would say the scale is a
lot more accurate but when I'm trying to
work out where plus and minus are the
scale is not as important I just want to
know where it's above the axis where
it's below okay and you can see it's the
same it's the same sections here
wow that was fatter than I realized here
and yeah right so you still got the same
solution okay now what would it look
like if I tried to draw the question as
originally presented X cubed minus 3x
squared is less than 4x well what it
means is you've got this guy over here
which is a particular function X cubed
minus 3x squared I could have asked you
to graph that as well and then you've
got this other function over here orange
for X we could graph that too and what
you're asking is when is that that one
on the left hand side which I've
highlighted in pink
when is it less than the one on the
right hand side which I've highlighted
in orange okay well this is what they
both look like let's just have it go
over here these are the two functions
right so when you have a look at this
we're asking when is that cubic one when
is it beneath the straight line one the
linear' one right and you can see if I
highlight let's let's go with orange
over here there's a section where the
cubic is beneath the straight line and
then there's also this section over here
where the cubic is below the straight
line now if you have a look at the
x-values that sort of correspond to that
if you just draw some dotted lines here
look that's negative one and then here
is zero all the way over to four so
you're getting the identical solution
but I hope you recognize that at least
in my brain that thing on the left is a
lot more simple to conceptualize than
the thing on the right the thing on the
right requires a lot more technical
accuracy to actually draw it properly or
is the thing on the left and we're much
better at doing confidently okay